uh now a few political parties have had
a tougher five years
than the lib dems after several brutal
election results
they've just elected their fifth
permanent leader in as many years the
former energy secretary said ed davey
is he the man to succeed while others
have failed and turn things around for
his party well let's ask him he joins us
now
thank you for being on the program
congratulations on your victory and
frankly of course you've got a mountain
to climb i'm going to start off with a
question
lots of our viewers might be asking what
exactly is the point of the lib dems
well liberal democrats stand first some
really key principles on social justice
on equality on civil liberties on
internationalism on protecting our
environment
but our message hasn't been getting over
to people over the last few elections
and what i'm saying as the leader is the
party needs to understand that
we need to wake up and smell the coffee
and we need to go out to the country
and we need to listen and we need to
understand why people don't think we're
on their side
we need to understand why people don't
think we represent their
values and that listening exercise is
something i'm going to lead over the
coming months i started it on friday in
stock pork
when i did a three hour lunch shift in a
fish and chip shop
and talk to the owners and bob talked to
their staff talked to their customers
and really began to understand the
issues that they faced
their problems their fears as well as
their hopes and
aspirations and i think that listening
exercise is the way that we can make
ourselves
relevant to people and uh and rebuild
relevant is the word and at the same
time though others have tried
before and failed tim farron vince cable
joe swinson why should you be any
different
well my colleagues did sterling jobs but
it was a difficult environment
obviously the biggest issue of the day
then was brexit we took a particular
position
i've always felt that we needed to not
just be a one-trick party we need to
talk about a whole range of issues
i'm particularly keen on the economy on
jobs
uh making sure particularly this
recession that we are the party
talking about the economy about green
jobs and the greener economy i've talked
about a fairer society
and a more caring country i want the
liberal democrats to be known for
all the values and all the ideas that we
have
but before we start talking about our
policies i think it's very important
that we listen and we shape our agenda
with our liberal values but we shape
that agenda to the concerns and fears
hopes and dreams of the british
people so i'm not going to sort of lay
out the policy agenda of the future what
i'm going to
lay out is how i'm going to listen to
people around the country the whole
country
so you say you don't want to lay out a
policy agenda and i get that you've only
just been in the job at the same time
listening to you these things are quite
vague i guess you know listening to
people
saying that you want to be you know firm
on the environment
on being fair on the society but what's
your
single radical policy the kind of thing
that's actually going to cut through to
the people you spoke to in the fish and
chip shop
well um sophie with respect if i'm doing
a listening exercise
it's not about one shift lunchtime shift
in a fish and chip shop that is the
start
of a whole setup single radical policy
that you that you want to offer
but but but sophie i want to listen
first
and i'm sorry if you find that vague and
unsatisfying but i think it's what
we ought to do in the liberal democrats
we've been sent a message in the last
three elections we've been very
disappointing and and we've not been
successful
and i want to face up to that and the
first way of facing up to that is not
setting out your radical agenda is
actually
listening and it's a serious exercise
um it's going to go on for months and
months i'm going to every part of the
country
and i'm going to be there peop with
people in their jobs in their
organizations
in their businesses we're going to be
talking to people who are carers
people who are teachers people in their
community and that is
how i think as leader of the liberal
democrats i can then
really understand people's issues and
fears and hopes and let's remember we
are at an
extraordinary moment in our country's
history in our world's history
covid is changing everything is to have
dramatic impact
on the country's health his particular
families
tragically and of course it's having a
massive impact on our economy and
the world's relations one's got to
understand
first of all how people are coping with
that and how politicians can reach out
and help them
but also what they're thinking about the
future postcovid you know what
what do they hope to that happens after
this do you want to go back to the
status ante
what it was like before or do they have
a hope that we can build something
better
and i want to listen to that to
understand what their dreams and hopes
are for a post-covid world
we've got the message on the listening
exercise loud and clear now
in an interview today uh david frost the
uk's chief brexit negotiator said the uk
won't blink first in the negotiations
what do you think the chances
of a trade deal are 50 higher lower
oh so if it's very difficult to know if
you're not in the room
but i do feel that the government is
being very reckless and risky we're in a
recession now it's uh
it wasn't foreseen when when brexit was
first talked of and during the
referendum
and at the last election this recession
due to kovid some people say may be the
worst recession deepest recession
for 300 years and in that context
the idea of a no deal brexit on top of
the coveted recession
i think would be a disaster for people's
jobs for people's livelihoods for
business up and down the country
and i thought it was very noticeable
last week
when businesses were saying the
government isn't prepared the borders
properly
whether it's a deal or a no deal they're
not ready
what has this government been doing
you know it's had a shambolic handling
of of covid
it's clearly not making the necessary
preparations
for a no deal brexit or any form of
brexit
and you know i am really really struck
by how businesses are becoming
more alarmed about how this government
is undertaking these negotiations so
we used to reel in these headlines how
tough they're going to be i want to know
are they going to be successful
for people's jobs and people's
livelihoods we're um
running out of time so just quickly um
could the lib dems campaign to rejoin
the eu in the future
look we've opposed brexit everybody
knows that
um but the government got a majority
they've pushed it through
um and now the issue is is there going
to be a deal or a node or the shape of
that
and then beyond that the issue is can we
have good relations with our european
friends and neighbors
we are a pro-european party i'm
passionately pro-european
i want to be as close to our european
friends and colleagues
as possible because that's in the
interests of the people of britain
okay i'm not clear on that answer still
look i mean i can't see us at the next
election
being anything other than pro-european
but i also think
we need to face the situation as it is
britain will have
left the european union i think the idea
that people want to
re revisit this uh in two or three years
time
okay um i think that's for the birds but
we will remain
passionately pro-european determined to
get the benefits of working with our
friends and neighbours
and just finally uh extinction rebellion
a few moments ago
diane abbott said that there were the
protests that they did
outside those printing presses were
legal that they were in a
tradition of the suffragettes in direct
action
do you agree with that
no i mean liberal democrats have been
passionate about tackling climate change
as climate change secretary i nearly
quadrupled britain's renewable park
we won very ambitious targets at the eu
and the united nations
that is the way we tackle climate change
working together
i think we need to bring the country
together to realize we have a climate
emergency
alongside the covet health and economic
emergency
my concern with what we saw was it
actually divides people
can undermine the message about the
climate emergency
and i fear when you damage the free
press in particular
that is shooting yourself in the foot
there was a interview
with david attenborough in one of those
newspapers that didn't get distributed
david attenborough is you know the
environment says par excellence
he has a lot to say about climate change
and how we protect our environment
i think stopping people reading david
attenborough is not a good message
okay ed davey thank you very much for
being on the programme today